[Music]
foreign
my name is hideyaki itsuno and I'm the
director of Dragon's Dogma 2. it's been
over a year since we celebrated 10 years
of Dragon's Dogma and I can finally give
you some more information about the new
game first let's take a look at the
trailer we revealed the other day
[Music]
thank you
not remember then have we forgotten that
you've protected me from the dragon's
flames you need only believe in your own
death
force that begs the question if he's a
man Mama then where might our true and
recently and presented in his life is in
your hands raise me for only the
sovereign
number one
[Music]
what did you think
the action RPG game Dragon's Dogma was
released in 2012.
now a decade later I'm proud to share a
look at the highly anticipated sequel
Dragon's Dogma 2.
today I want to talk about two
characteristics that Dragon's Dogma 2
will inherit from its predecessor
first Dragon's Dogma 2 will be a single
player game but with pawns at your side
it will feel like Co-op
and second gameplay will feature action
role-playing mechanics set in an open
world environment in the Dragon's Dogma
series you embark on your adventures
with pawns other worldly beings
controlled by AI alongside the
player-controlled Arisen you can embark
on your journey with a Main Pawn that
can be customized to your liking as well
as up to two additional support pawns
you can borrow from other players
to form a party of up to four characters
pawns are controlled by the AI and are
now capable of even more precise
decisions than in the previous title
helping you in the midst of battles
they can also help guide you to new
locations
core give you a high five following a
successful battle it really feels like
playing in a party with other players
Dragon's Dogma 2 is built with the re
engine resulting in a dense World woven
with high graphical Fidelity you'll
enjoy a world roughly four times the
size of the original Dragon's Dogma with
more to experience than ever before the
characters and monsters that populate
the world are given life thanks to the
power of AI and players will feel like
they've been reborn in this vibrant
fantasy world you can look forward to a
variety of vocations to choose from your
vocation will shape your arisen's role
throughout the adventure will you take
on enemies with swords magic it's all up
to you we'll have much more to share in
the future but for now
I want to go over a few sections from
the trailer that show what we've
improved for Dragon's Dogma 2.
[Music]
this game is designed to enable players
to take on situations in their own way
in addition to AI advanced technology
like immersive physics brings pawns
monsters and NPCs to life
what would happen if you destroyed that
bridge or if you pulled that Monster's
leg
what other exciting possibilities can
you think of
meet two characters pivotal to the story
that also appear in the game's key art
urika a bow wielder with a deep
connection to the erisic and nadenia a
high priestess of the B string which
appear in the series for the first time
what Destiny awaits how will they affect
your fate the intricate relationships
and situations you will encounter in the
game are sure to keep you on your toes
[Music]
during your adventure you will come
across familiar monsters from the
previous game as well as new monsters
such as Medusa you can look forward to
new player vocations and many new
experiences unique to Dragon's Dogma 2.
please stay tuned for more information
thank you so much for tuning in
[Music]
drag